[Música]
[Aplausos]
muito boa tarde
venho cá falar vos de um sonho mas
também vêm cá falar vos de
responsabilidade social
bem antes pra quem não conhece que a
faça uma pequena introdução é meu nome é
sair de neto
eu tive um ato de responsabilidade
social involuntária logo à nascença
eu não ache na sagrada família no carro
não espera aí instou aos meus pais é a
lavagem completa do carro mas
posteriormente eu é que sei os
infelizmente hoje negociaram é quando
tinha nove anos e aos nove anos
é como se sentir responsável pelos meus
irmãos mais novos
aos 15 anos já trabalhava montará
andaremos em lisboa no ano seguinte é
cumprir a promessa que tinha com os meus
irmãos mais novos enviados para portugal
a nos anos já tinha enviado por e mail
uma bicicleta que os tinham pedido para
poder se deslocar da casa que ficava
distante da escola importante acho que
compensa os meus pais
ok o meu sonho eu tenho um sonho de ver
uma sociedade em harmonia sustentada por
valores morais cívicos e éticos e que
tenha na educação e na formação continua
as suas principais alavancas para o
desenvolvimento sócio econômico
sustentado para a senhora não pois é
é um sonho que eu tenho feito tudo o que
posso para tentar alcançar a vida nesta
sociedade cria um modelo khan um modelo
econômico que ia controlar a
desigualdade de rendimentos
este modelo econômico estava obviamente
baseado na educação
portanto não prometeria que ninguém que
é isso abaixo do nível de referência
médio é desigualdade econômica
viajei pra inglaterra e foi uma economia
teve uma função de produção muito
curiosa com drogas foi shankar alguns
economistas na na sala a função de
produção simplesmente transacciona a
quantidade produzida com os fatores de
produção
ok talvez ponte no relacionava isso que
adicionava tecnologia vem é temos apenas
que é igual a uma constante vezes o
capital vez well que é a força de
trabalho e tai levantado o capital
levantado a tecnologia o corpo de drogas
levantou também o a força de trabalho a
tecnologia
ok é que é trazida a diferença é que nós
vamos levantar a força de trabalho a um
índice de educacional e o que é este
índice educacional não é nada mais nada
menos do que a formação vezes
responsabilidade social e
responsabilidade social o que é moral e
civismo e épica e ao tentar descortinar
esta função
cheguei à conclusão que há a função da
produção do corpo do gancho
podia muito bem ser resumida a uma
função em que a força de trabalho estava
exponencial nada a responsabilidade
social para dizer que sempre que a
responsabilidade social subir vai haver
uma progressão geométrica o meia hora a
produção vai disparar quando há muita
responsabilidade social
o inverso também é verdadeiro
se houver pouca responsabilidade social
isto é pouca moral e civismo e ética
para os matemáticos nessa aula é fácil
ver que esta será a responsabilidade
social for negativa e tender para ao
menos infinito
a produção teve prazer estamos no
terreno familiar não
portanto quando não há responsabilidade
social
a produção é com a 0 ok eu passei um
caminho mais adiante foi buscar a outra
a outra
a outra função da procura agregada e
cheguei a uma conclusão curiosa é que na
eventualidade da responsabilidade social
tender para - infinito
a procura agregada fica dependente da
importação
também estamos não também familiar não
pois é que o cd que é que é o conjunto
de produtos domésticos mais as despesas
do governo
mas o investimento na exportação
anulados porque não existe produção
nacional
não existe produção e ficarmos
dependentes da importação
parece mau gosto pensei quando os níveis
de responsabilidade social são muito
muito baixos ou negativos
o homem um ambiente social e econômico
degradadas consideravelmente criando
fatores negativos que se alimentam uns
aos outros a crise econômica a pobreza
ausência de referências ausência da
autoridade moral situações de
responsabilidade coletiva e às vezes
cultural
nós ouvimos falar da crise do subprime
marca que nos afetou aqui também
acho que a epa para a maior parte dos
economistas é pacífico que esta crise é
mais uma crise e responsabilidade do que
propriamente uma crise do dos papéis do
título
portanto valer muita responsabilidade
social naquela crise
portanto já que a responsabilidade
social é tão importante o que podemos
fazer para elevar o nível de
responsabilidade social a nível do
estado políticas sociais mais
condizentes ajudariam o tal modelo
econômico que não permite que a
desigualdade a atingir a um certo nível
também ajudaria muito nós temos da manhã
as leis do mecenato hoje que permitem um
incentivo para as empresas serem as
cenas e também o próprio estado pode
promover programas internos de
responsabilidade social a nível das
empresas as empresas deviam como
acontece na ilha adotaria uma política
de responsabilidade social em que
comprometiam sem realizar certas
atividades sobretudo partilhar a parte
dos seus resultados
também as empresas devem incluir a a
ferramenta da responsabilidade social no
seu plano estratégico e de negócios
portanto não se deveria fazer negócio
sem a componente de responsabilidade
social porque já vimos que no limite
o negócio é ficar sem produção a nível
dos particulares
os portugueses deve enveredar por uma
conduta de responsabilidade social a
todo o tempo inclusive eu devia ter um
registo de atos de irresponsabilidade
social
de vez em quando eu faço hoje sudeste e
no final de semana no final do mês
tento corrigir um ou outro um outro ato
que cometi de forma voluntária e os
vezes involuntária
ainda na iniciativa dos particulares
eu aproveito para introduzirmos o
projeto rede de suporte educacional
este é um projecto de uma fundação onde
eu sou responsável ea visão da fundação
é mais ou menos semelhante à visão que
mostrei no início uma sociedade harmonia
sustentada por valores morais cívicos e
éticos e que tenha na educação e na
formação contínua as suas principais
alavancas para o desenvolvimento sócio
econômico sustentável
quero antes de dizer vos colocam este
projecto começou eu fui assim e por
extensão nenhuma criança pediu dinheiro
para comprar cadernos
normalmente as crianças pedem para
comprar a bolo pão pois o chile antes
mas achei estranho primeiro dia pedirem
dinheiro para comprar cadeira
ajudei a criança e posteriormente serão
nas nossas crianças não iam à escola por
quantias mínimas
fui lá as nossas averiguar e consegue
apoiar ali as crianças em são tomé de
volta pra angola num certo dia fui
assaltado por é jovens em idade escolar
e levaram o carro até hoje está em 2012
ok no primeiro dia naturalmente muito
chateado mas no segundo dia já estava eu
a perguntar a mim o que eu posso fazer
para ajudar os jovens a conhecer algumas
pessoas que apresentaram algumas
famílias desfavorecidas aqui em angola e
eu comecei a apoiar estas famílias
favorecidas apoiar as crianças
é trabalho trabalho na banca
aqueles com 500 em e tem um quem tenho
colegas maravilhosos
eu apresentei a o projeto a else
gostaram deram força
conseqüência surgiu a surgiu a
necessidade de expandir o projeto e para
expandir o projeto precisava de criar
uma instituição que desse suporte cria
uma fundação e assim surge a fundação de
apoio à educação tem neste momento tem
neste momento é 3 projeto quatro
projetos rock é esquecer o chile tem
neste momento quatro projetos o primeiro
projecto chama-se rede suporte
educacional
este projeto visa dar apoio a algumas
famílias carenciadas de maneira elas
porém manter as crianças na escola e
esta foi compreende duas componentes uma
financeira nós injetamos 2.500 casas por
criança no máximo três crianças pro gato
familiar
a outra componente é pedagógica e o
educativa o nosso usamos alunos do
ensino médio e universitário estes
alunos de uma onça casa destas crianças
pelo menos uma vez por mês e dá um apoio
com relação à matemática português
literacia financeira e acima de tudo
servir de referência para os mil dias
[Aplausos]
o projeto conta neste momento com mais
de 1700 crianças receberem apoio
financeiro eo pedagógico uma proeza de
mentores que já ultrapassa 400 mentores
pretendemos chegar até o final do ano
aos 1000 mentores portanto os mentores
figuras principais do projeto são alunos
do ensino médio e universitário que ao
praticarem esta responsabilidade social
cultiva esse valores fundamentais não só
pra eu os próprios mais como para a
sociedade
já os nossos futuros gestores que estão
a caminho neste momento
aproveito para pedir uma salva de palmas
pra els questão a tal nos bairros neste
momento é trabalhar porque não estamos
em campanha de solidariedade educacional
que eu vou falar já seguida o plantel é
o prêmio é o primeiro e principal vetor
da fundação o segundo que é um subsetor
do primeiro chama centro de duque
nós em angola neste momento temos
qualquer coisa como 2011 mais crianças
fora do sistema de ensino é uma
preocupação
então decidimos a nível da fundação
ajudar o estado o governo a incluir um
milhão de crianças no sistema educativo
como é que vamos fazer isto nós vamos
criar escolas no interior dos bairros
vamos criamos criamos escola no interior
dos bairros
o plano estratégico este ano em que
procurava a criação de quatro escolas
nós já eu já inaugurei a primeira no
golfo e já temos treino pra mais duas
estamos à procura da terceira para
cumprirmos o plano estratégico sem a
ajuda de empresas de pessoas do bem
obviamente que não conseguimos e por
isso peço ajuda de todos para é
colocarmos um milhão de crianças nas
escolas
portanto ceducs é o segundo vetor da
fundação o terceiro vetor e quetta
ennals chamas prêmio do que eu treinar
os realizamos duas edições do prêmio
educar onde atribuímos prêmios às
pessoas singulares ou coletivas cuja
contribuição para a educação é tida como
relevante
este é a última edição do prêmio que
realizou sem 2016 descontinuamos porque
nós podemos ajudar todos e entretanto
vamos atribuir prémios apenas alguns
achamos que precisamos repensar e tardes
continuado por enquanto
o quarto vetor é uma campanha de
solidariedade educacional
estamos agora numa e da campanha neste
mês
nesta campanha nós promovemos a
solidariedade entre os percursos que não
tenha recursos para aceder à educação
nós é rezar mais diversas atividades
durante a campanha desde atividades
culturais esportivas e também
distribuímos qualquer coisa com 10 mil
crachás deste e queremos que estes
crachá se torna em cima da solidariedade
educacional importante eu vou tentar que
o pessoal da educa juntam aqui mais de
900 pessoas
não sei se temos que achar suficientes
mas eu vou tentar que todos recebam
estes quatro vetores posicionados de
forma estratégicas devem nos permitir
expandir a educação para todos é levar o
nível educacional da população e
aumentar o índice de responsabilidade
social aumentando o índice de
responsabilidade social
acredito que teremos todos uma sociedade
mas sá mais saudável
quem vem aqui alguns números da da
campanha a idéia do projeto mas aceitar
juntar com valor de metade está muito
pequeno príncipe pouco perceptível é e
não vou não vou tocar neles mas
basicamente a meta mais importante é
incluir um milhão de crianças até 2030
no sistema de no sistema de ensino
esta é nossa meta este é o desafio que
eu conto com todos vós
quero agradecer a oportunidade que até
dex mandato estar aqui falar da
responsabilidade social
quero deixar uma mensagem também as
empresas a responsabilidade social tem
pa
positivo na performance financeira da
empresa cada vez terá mais porque nós
estamos pronto um público mais exigente
que obviamente vai vai querer ter é é a
vai querer ter um contato com empresas
que praticam responsabilidade social a
nível interno
já existem várias empresas a incluírem a
responsabilidade social como uma
ferramenta no seu plano estratégico e
com resultados bem visíveis poços dar o
exemplo do banco bai por exemplo e mais
algumas outras instituições que têm
enfeites já com muito sucesso
por isso eu recomendo vivamente que os
líderes das empresas implementem a
ferramenta de responsabilidade social
porque tem impacto a nível interno e a
nível externo na percepção que nós temos
de uma empresa que era responsável é
responsável pela sociedade também
muito obrigado não vou prolongar mais
muito obrigado pela atenção
[Aplausos]